there was developments today in the case
of britney spears's conservatorship
which we are covering
as a story fox's trace gallagher has the
very latest for us hey trace hey tucker
britney spears appears to be on the road
to victory but it's unclear exactly how
long that road is court documents show
her father jamie spears is willing to
step down as her conservator when the
time is right the court papers show that
jamie spears still believes he's the
best person to handle his daughter's
financial affairs and also believes
there are no legal grounds for removing
him but jamie spears attorney writes in
part quoting here even as mr spears is
the unremitting target of unjustified
attacks he does not believe that a
public battle with his daughter over his
continuing service as her conservator
would be in her best interest so it's
going to happen we just don't know when
britney spears attorney calls it
vindication and is pleased that jamie
spears has agreed to be replaced jamie
spears of course has been his daughter's
conservator since she suffered a very
public breakdown 13 years ago but during
those 13 years britney has repeatedly
toured the world and released
multiple albums her fans say she can
take care of herself
tucker
trace gallagher for us tonight thanks so
much you bet
so hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else